what we're gonna do in this video is do
a few examples ordering numbers that
involve decimals so let's say that we
had the numbers one point zero zero one
zero point one one three and one point
one zero one what I would like you to do
is order these numbers from least to
greatest take out some paper and try to
do it on your own before we do it
together all right now let's do it
together
and the way I would tackle ordering
numbers is I would go to the largest
place value that the numbers have in
common and so in this situation we have
a ones place value in all of them and so
we could see that this has one one this
has zero ones and this one has one one
so the thing that has the least ones is
going to be the smallest of the numbers
so this one over here is going to be the
smallest of the number so let me just
write that over here zero point 1 1 3
and now we have to figure out which one
is next between one point zero zero one
and one point one zero one well then we
just go to the next place value so we go
to to the tenths place and we see right
over here they're equal on the ones
place so if you go to the tenths place
this one has zero tenths well this one
has one tenth so the number on the right
here is going to be larger it has more
tents same number of ones but it has
more tents it doesn't really matter what
happens to the right of that so the next
smallest number if we're ordering from
least to greatest is going to be one
point zero zero one and then last but
not least would be this one that is the
largest one point one zero one let's do
another example let's say we had the
numbers zero point four two four zero
point three four three and zero point
four four three pause this video and try
to order these from least to greatest on
your own and once again the idea here is
always start with the largest place
value and then compare and then keep
moving to the right if some things are
equal all right now let's do this
together so they all have zero ones so
they're all equal there so that's not
going to tell us much so now let's go to
the tenths place so here I have four
tenths here I have three tenths
here I have four tenths so I don't you
have to look at the hundredths or the
thousands place this one has the least
tenths so I can put that as the least or
the smallest of the three numbers is
0.34 three and now so I've already used
that one and so I need to compare these
two numbers they have the same number of
ones they have the same number of tenths
so then we move to the hundredths so
here I have two hundredths here I have
four hundredths this one has less
hundredths than this one so the one on
the left is going to be the next
smallest number so then we have zero
point four two four and then last but
not least this one right over here it
has the same number of ones as
everything else it has more tense than
this middle one and the same number of
tenths as the left one but then it has
but then it also has more hundredths
than the left one right over here so
this is the largest of the numbers zero
point four four three and we're done